Archer better protect your bubble calm
proud sponsors of swype on Sky News
you're watching swipe stay with us to
find out what we're doing in the middle
of the English countryside with dogs and
if nothing to do with hunting tech I
promise give a dog a drone we're off on
a mission with a search and rescue team
using airborne technology more flying
robots to the rescue we look at UAVs
destined for emergency situations and
time is of the essence in our games
review to this week we've got a
SmartWatch special including titles to
play on the new Apple watch hello and
welcome to swipe this week were with the
national search and rescue dog
association in kent now that might not
sound very techy but wait till you see
the new drone they've been trying out
every year in the UK around 200,000
people are reported missing so perhaps a
little help from a UAV that's an
unmanned aerial vehicle might make all
the difference in some of those cases
now the team of volunteers here today
have very kindly said we can join them
on a mock rescue mission to see how the
drone might work once they start to use
it for real and it all begins over there
James row what's happening right now
well we're running a training exercise
today and we've got a missing person the
guy call steve holman who's the local
farmer here your pretend missing pet
he's out for tonight I no one's really
miss it good tonight so we've set a
snare up for our guys we're gonna test
some new technology out today on the
search that we've been donated by 02 we
found this guy's quad bike out in the
lane line
and so we are vide up here razavi me Ron
Davis we've brought the team together to
where we are on that exactly these guys
will take a briefing we're then going to
fly the drone get a good look at the
Langley want to see what kind of
information it can give us about this is
looking at maps to where you think the
missing person is what they've done it
when those maps we the search manager
Stuart here is designed into search
areas based on some based on lot
statistics we collect about missing
person behavior and what we want to do
is validate with the drone that the map
actually represents what we have here on
the ground because hedgerows move
woodlands change stuff gross stuff gets
cut down so this looks intriguing game
so this is the drone this will give us a
live video feed from above the searcher
also recalled in 1080p high-definition
the same stuff you broadcasting on sky
so we should be able to get some really
good imagery from this we can compare it
to the mapping we've got in the van
we're not exactly what it looks like
today if there any hazards out there and
we can take our resources and put the
right resource in the right place to get
the best result of finding this person
when I get it up high up in the air
we're going to leave it hovering spin it
round get a good video of the area we're
going to bring it back we're going to
review the high-res video and make some
decisions where we send our search guys
to go looking so I'll just go into the
camera here get to the SD card pop it
out hopefully that's the magic sauce
that we're after on that that we're
going have a look at me lose it on the
way small isn't it just drop the dome
down a bit low and if ice move through
the video clip
oh look what rousers a coat that we're
not sure so what we need to do I pause
it there we need to send a team out find
out is that relevant to our search is it
a missing person we've got this evidence
of where this jacket was so we've got
some good clues we're gonna send the
foot team they're going to go recover
that search on the way in person oh it
looks like the dogs found something
behind us you just come back to the
handler there the dogs ever outrun my
handler all the time the dog add dogs
are trained on site they're trained on
something called a refi to the dog will
go to the body come back to its handler
alert in Tess's case it's a Joe dog seen
one this is control send your message we
will need a finger in search and rescue
have all this technology all these tools
and it's about taking a really small
resource and putting it in the right
place to get the right result anything
that helps us do that drones GPS radios
statistics anything it's just another
great step forward for us and how we can
take new technology and actually get
some real life saving results from it
thanks for showing us how it's all done
no problem you're watching wife coming
up we find out if gaming on the new
Apple watch is any good or just a waste
of time sorry I couldn't help it so the
rescue mission was successful but these
guys aren't the only ones experimenting
with flying robots and emergency
situations I've been taking a look at
what else is out there swimmers have
been given peace of mind on some of the
beaches in Chile recently a project
there who've seen the testing of drones
carrying life preservers but can get to
you before a lifeguard in Norway
researchers have been trying out a
flying robot to see how it could help
rescuers in avalanche situations the
drone can spot body heat and fly in
heavy winds 30 minutes after an
avalanche the survival rate is only
thirty percent oh such events can have
deadly consequences as we saw when last
month's earthquake in Nepal triggered an
avalanche on Everest
now anything flying through the air
risks colliding with something so here's
one designed to be crushproof so it
doesn't need to avoid obstacles in
disaster situations its protective
rotating cage means it just bounces off
we were thinking insects can reach
places while flying that are impossible
to reach with our current technology and
one of their key capability is to
collide into things and continue flying
to survive collisions and we wanted to
reproduce these amazing capabilities
with our drone another BOTS taking tips
from nature is this floppy winged one
from scientists at America's Stanford
University the wings mean it can fold up
and move through difficult spaces if
there is a building collapse then they
no longer do you have a nice hallway
that you can fly through you're going to
have pieces of scraps that have just
fallen everywhere you aren't going to
know what they are ahead of time to plan
your pass around them and this bush fire
in Australia was filmed using a UAV
firefighters there have been testing how
drone technology could help them UAVs
are already used by fire crews in
America it's pretty obvious how every
second counts in emergency situations
and actually time is something that's
been on our minds quite a lot to in the
swype team recently it must have
something to do with all the hype around
the Apple watch launch and the growth of
the SmartWatch market as a whole which
is why this week guy Kaka has picked a
few titles for your wrist in our games
review spy watch is a new game for the
Apple watch which has just been released
a couple of weeks ago and it's a novel
concept obviously the watch is a new
kind of games console in a lot of ways
the idea is that you're running your
agency and you send your agents out into
the field and train them up and every
kind of few hours or so you'll get a
message from your agent so you might get
a message from your agent who's out in
Paris saying I'm a guard post do I take
the guy out or do I try and sneak past
him and you make that decision for him
it's kind of just this experience that
comes through via short notifications
much shorter than a tweet a lot of
people might find that a little bit
intrusive coming through to their wrist
watch all the time but there's this
weird thing that happens after
a few hours where you start to actually
believe that you do have these agents
out in the field or maybe that was just
me another game for the Apple watch that
I review this week is watch quest and if
the spy watch is an example of how to do
a watch based game effectively then
watch quest is an example of how to do
it badly you could send this little guy
out on a on a quest he goes wandering
for say 30 minutes you have to keep
checking in on him to make sure that
he's fed it fed effectively you have to
keep digging for gold this feels like
I'm having to go on my watch all the
time and tap things it's not really that
fun or engaging but it is free so if you
just bought an Apple watch it is free if
you want to check it out Apple watch is
not the only watched technology in town
there's also Android wear and there's a
number of different Android watches out
there some of the games I've been
playing on them a really good one is
called by dots and it's one of those
kind of puzzle experiences that you see
a lot on mobile devices it's frustrating
but very enjoyable hell while you're
playing it separating these balls out
into different sections of the square
while it's a great game to play because
it takes literally a few seconds to play
around of the game your finger actually
covers a good portion of the screen it's
one of those games that not quite there
in terms of the watch but really one of
those experiences that you can dip into
and I've been playing it a lot this week
final game for for Android wear is swipe
with a 3 instead of the e which is an
appropriate game for this particular
show you're always swiping from once one
of the four sides of the watch screen
you have to combine three or more colors
to make them disappear swipe is actually
a really kind of charming and nice
experience the only thing to say against
it is that it's you have to pay for its
99p but it's not too much and it works
on both your android phone and your
android what you want well that's it for
this week but don't forget you can stay
up to date with all the latest tech
stories on Sky News for iPad or
smartphone apps guyanese calm and our
youtube playlist see you again next week
bye bye say bye bye bye
Archer ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News